ils font tellement partie du paysage que
bien souvent les oublions ne les
remarque plus pourtant les murs en
pierres sèches sont des constructions
très importante dans les aménagements de
locaux tôt ça va servir aussi pour les
viticulteurs à maintenir leurs parcelles
de vignes qui sont souvent en pente donc
ça va retenir la terre retenir l'eau
aussi est donc ça évite les glissements
de terrain et ça permet de préserver les
cultures et puis la troisième chose ça
va être de préserver la biodiversité
parce que les interstices qu'on trouve
dans ses murs vont abriter une faune et
une flore qui va s'y trouvaient bien et
s'y installer ce petit lézard qui
profite d'un beau mur en pierre a tout
de même de la chance car son habitat est
bien souvent souffrance par manque de
temps beaucoup de ces bâtis ne sont plus
entretenues et s'écroule il faut bien
l'avouer ce type de construction
nécessite un certain savoir faire et
c'est justement ce que sont venus
chercher des stagiaires ça va me
permettre de connaître un peu plus de
choses sur le patrimoine déjà et pouvoir
l'utiliser après chez moi pour en
construire un pour que notre maison
s'inscrit dans le paysage
durant trois jours ils vont tout
apprendre toutes les ficelles du parfait
bâtisseur à commencer par le vocabulaire
les gabarits c'est ça alors au départ on
pose les premières pierres ce
département après un calage derrière on
garde un fruit en descendant poli de
pouvoir donner une pente
au mur et après ben en faire des outils
pour travailler le caillou la bouche
arbres têtu le pointu le ciseau le
maillet la masse autre particularité des
murs en pierres sèches
ils sont montés sans mortier c'est juste
posé oui il faut aplanir que que la
pierre soit bien calé qu'elle bouge plus
c'est un peu tetris en pierre un jeu un
plaisir de travailler la pierre sans
stress ni concours de vitesse
chacun va à son rythme pour mieux
appréhender les bons gestes afin plus
tard d'entretenir ses murs et rendre
encore plus jolies les paysages du sud
bourgogne